[Musique]
monsieur bonsoir cet homme qui est
derrière moi est à la tête d'une des
plus grosses fortunes de france est un
des dix grands leaders de l'économie
française c'est le baron empain
et bien ce matin il a été enlevé en
plein paris alors qu'il est personne
n'est capable de dire quel est le mobile
du rapt aucune demande de rançon n'a été
formulée
alors s'agit-il donc d'un rapt à
l'italienne du style de celui de
monsieur révelli beaumont en avril
dernier
ou bien d'un enlèvement à l'allemande
comme celui de hans martin schleyer en
septembre rien ne permet encore de le
dire avenue foch rival des champs
elysées quant au prestige et le lieu de
résidence préférée des plus riches
familles
c'est dans la contre-allée de droite que
l'enlèvement a eu lieu peu avant 11
heures lorsque la 604 venait de quitter
le numéro 33 domicile du baron empain
hauteur du numéro 10 est un cyclomoteur
lui a barré la route d'une camionnette
est là en stationnement de gangsters
masqué en surgissent revolver braqué le
cyclomotoriste lui aussi sort un
pistolet le baron empain est emmené dans
sa propre voiture par deux hommes seuls
véritables témoins du rapt
le chauffeur qui a été jeté dans les
staffs est et qui devaient être relâchés
peu après porte maillot
la concierge du 17 bis a pu cependant
fournir quelques vagues indications
10h et 10h30 il n'y avait rien je suis
descendu et j'avais appelé la police
pour dans les rangs d'une voiture ce
qu'il est totalement différent de la
faire et à ce moment-là croyais assez de
la bolliger entendu du bruit des
craquements de portières et une voiture
redémarrer et vous avez entendu du bruit
j'ai entendu du bruit j'ai entendu des
craquements de portières
[Musique]